- [Adam Lefkoe:] Is Karl-Anthony Towns underrated?
Ooh. Gets it back.
Ahhh.
- [Karl-Anthony Towns:] Look at him.
Look what I did to him with one move!
- Look what you did to that T-Rex.
- One move!
- Welcome to "Underrated,"
the only show that improves
the video game ratings of your favorite
professional athletes.
Today, that's Karl-Anthony Towns,
two-time All-Star.
Let's go to our professional
2K gamer Davisss
to see how he stacks up in the game.
- [ImDavisss:] Karl-Anthony Towns, the man's a superstar.
Me personally, what I look
for is someone that can rebound strong,
handle the rock just a little bit
and can definitely spread the floor
and hit the open passer
when the double-team comes in the post.
- [Lefkoe:] I was looking at your rating.
- [Towns laughing]
- The one that stuck out to me
is your passing rating.
I think you're a pretty good passer.
- I appreciate it.
- I've seen it. I've seen—what are you,
4.5 assists last year?
- Yeah.
- I mean, you were like one below
D'Angelo Russell.
What do you think
your passer rating was?
Do you know this?
- As a big man, they always
kind of put it down a little bit.
- Sure.
- So I'll probably say, like, high 70s.
- High 70s.
- Low 80s.
- What if I were to tell you, Karl-Anthony Towns,
that it is 60?
- 60 what?
Just a, nope, just a flat 60.
- What the f--k.
Where's Ronnie?
- [Lefkoe:] This is the
wonderful, the illuminary,
the prescient Ronnie 2K, everybody.
- You got a problem with that passing rating?
Let's fix it.
- Man...let's go get it going.
- Aight, you have my eyeballs.
- Yup.
- Let's see if we can get passing up a little bit.
- We sat Ronnie and his beautiful brain in a room,
and we came up with some drills.
- OK.
- And so the first drill that we have
is to improve that passer rating,
and I think we can improve it a bunch, too.
- Yeah, we can get it up.
- If he performs really poorly, though, could it also go down?
- Of course it could.
- OK, sure.
- So if I throw it off the ceiling, for example—
- Yeah. Or you like hit a camera guy
in the back of the head?
- I think that we may get sued.
I think that could be worse
than the rating.
- [Lefkoe:] Let's challenge the assumption
that great insurance is only available
at high rates, while KAT gets a chance
to challenge the assumption
that a big man can't dish the ball.
Here's how this is gonna work.
- [Towns:] OK.
- I want you to drive the lane,
and I don't, I don't want you to take it easy.
I want like a game-speed drive,
and then a kick-out,
and we're gonna do it
three times, and the target's
gonna get smaller each time.
What are you looking for as he does this?
- Look, I mean he—this is very important to him.
I expect precision.
- OK.
If you really hate your 60 rating, now is the chance.
- Whenever you're ready.
That was a good pass, though.
- It was a good pass.
But this is where it really steps up.
- Ooooh! You see that? I didn't even hit
any part of the white. The bullseye's
the only thing that got hit. Damn.
- [Lefkoe:] Whenever you're ready, Karl.
- [Towns:] All right.
- [Ronnie 2K:] Here we go. Here we go.
- [Lefkoe:] Oh! Drilled it. There
wasn't a doubt in his mind. He's got the big smile.
- [Ronnie:] He's just staring me down.
- I told you!
- He's just staring at Ronnie right now.
- Yeah, that alone, this didn't move.
- Are you intimidated at all?
- I mean, he didn't even touch the pole.
That was as clean as it gets.
- Very impressed.
- Yeah.
- Congratulations.
- Got a lot to think about.
- Gotta be honest, though,
we went back and talked about it.
We need to see longer passes.
So we're gonna do the opposite,
which is instead of finishing a break,
starting a break.
- OK.
- We're gonna do some outlet passes down here,
all the way out here.
- OK.
- Let's see what you got.
All right, Karl. Outlet passes.
3, 2, 1.
Ooh! Is that considered a hit?
- [Ronnie:] That was pretty close.
- [Lefkoe:] I mean…
- You said hit it.
- [Lefkoe:] He did hit it.
- [Ronnie] That was pretty close.
- I mean, the man baseball-passed it.
Randy Johnsoned the ball right there.
Now it is time for
basketball-on-basketball crime.
Oh! Shattered.
- Fatality.
- [Lefkoe making sound of unsheathing sword] Finish him.
- [Ronnie:] That was impressive. I gotta… we got a lot to discuss.
- [Lefkoe:] Well done, well done.
- [Ronnie] You have made it very difficult for us
not to reconsider that rating.
That was impressive.
- Appreciate you.
- The rating is going up guaranteed.
- Yeah, for sure.
- The amount that it's going up?
- [Ronnie] I feel like the 70 is a no-doubter.
- [Laughing]
- Congratulations.
- Appreciate it.
- Next up we have for you, though, is rebounding.
- OK, cool.
- The Worm rating.
- [ImDavisss:] Karl-Anthony Towns definitely needs
his Worm badge upgraded.
The Worm badge is necessary
for getting rebounds in 2K, all right,
and him having it in bronze
is absolutely ridiculous.
We've already seen his footwork.
We already know he can make position
for himself in the paint
and do everything necessary
to get the rebounds.
So 2K, why is his Worm badge only on bronze?
- The reason we're doing this is because
you have a bronze Worm rating.
So this is your opportunity
to upgrade that.
- [Towns:] I had—I'm in top five in rebounding
like every year
since I've been in, right?
- Ronnie. I know.
- [Ronnie:] I know.
- [Lefkoe:] We have, uh, some obstacles for you.
They're a little prehistoric.
Here's how this is gonna work, Karl.
We're gonna have a shooter from the top of the key.
- [Towns:] OK.
- [Lefkoe:] He's gonna put up five shots.
- [Towns:] Got it.
- [Lefkoe:] The ball can only hit the ground
in the entire drill four times.
- OK.
- If you're able to do that,
bronze, silver, badgin' up.
- Yup.
- [Lefkoe:] Are you ready?
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
- [Ronnie:] All right, let's do this.
- [Lefkoe:] OK, first one.
Ooh. Oh, gets it back.
Aah!
- [Towns:] Look at him! Look what I did to him with one move.
- [Lefkoe:] Look what you did to that T-Rex.
- [Towns:] One move!
Ronnie, forget Worm.
That's Bruiser right there.
- They extinct again.
- Come on.
- You just made him extinct.
- They should've stayed down years ago.
- Two down. Two bounces.
Both very impressive.
And he's ready. No bounce.
And the dunk.
- I love it.
- Man, get yourself up. Come on. We got two more.
Damn. Let's go.
- [Lefkoe:] Fourth shot. Boxing out. Gets it.
- [Ronnie:] Oh my God! The whole team gone.
- Did that—I don't think that ball hit the ground that time, did it?
- Nope.
- So one shot, and you can afford one bounce.
- Two bounces. One bounce.
- Ready?
- [Lefkoe:] 1, 2, gets it, no bounce.
Your official thoughts?
- I'm very, very impressed.
- How did it feel?
- Yeah, it was good. You know,
Ronnie gotta be proven wrong again.
- [Ronnie laughing]
- So I had to come out here and put,
tie my shoes on and then, you know,
just tried to do everything.
They tried to give me a beach ball.
- [Lefkoe:] Yup.
- Tried to give me a target.
- Yup.
- Tried to give me another basketball
- That was—that was some "Inception" stuff.
- And then you took it up to a baseball throw.
- Yeah, right?
And then, and then you gave me
some prehistoric animals.
- [Ronnie:] I mean, that was impressive.
You can just tell over there. Undoubted—
- No-doubter?
- No-doubter. He's a silver.
- Wow.
- So today your passing went up 10 points.
You went up a badge
in terms of the Worm.
And now it's my favorite thing to do
is to put Ronnie on the spot.
Is Karl-Anthony Towns underrated?
- With everything I saw?
Absolutely. Absolutely underrated.
My man.
- He said it!
That means it's real!
- You looked good. I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- And that's why we do "Underrated."
Karl-Anthony Towns, underrated. Congratulations.
- Appreciate you.